et en politique et les élus de saint
quentin faisait hier leur rentrée 38
points étaient à l'ordre du jour
économie à budget ou encore
environnement où on fait le point sur la
séance s'est dit hier soir avec vous
wilfrid est riche
bonsoir alors on commence avec des
sujets qui ont fait débat entre majorité
et opposition notamment un projet
d'aménagement celui de la gare des
cannes à la verrière bonsoir floral un
projet qui n'était même pas à 100 c'est
être à l'ordre du jour mais nelly duthu
la mère de la verrière a pris la parole
pendant le conseil d'agglomération
accompagné des élus de sa majorité
municipale qui était présent dans le
public
elle a évoqué un blocage de la part de
l'agglomération à l'annoncé elle son
intention de confier la maîtrise
d'ouvragé à l'état cette zac de la gare
bekale en détail c'est à terme 1800
logements construits à la création d'un
pôle d'activité de 80 mille mètres
carrés et un pôle multimodal également
tout ça pour une ville est de 6000
habitants où vous l'avez compris c'est
un projet d'envergure michel logis le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
elle s'est donc défendu il dénonce lui
le choix fait par la ville de confier ce
projet à l'état il veut simplement que
l'on prenne plus de temps sur un dossier
et ce récit structurants en consultant
par exemple est les villes voisines
comme celles d'el en cours qui serait
fortement et forcément impactées alors
votre si j'ai attendu le vote de
certaines subventions pour des
associations devraient composer a
principalement problème celui de
l'association pour le rayonnement de
port royal des champs les élus ont voté
une baisse de la subvention de près 750
euros une décision qui a dénoncé la
gauche et surtout à bertrand guillon le
maire ps de magny-les-hameaux la
majorité s'est finalement engagé à
revoir ce montant et puis les élus
devaient se prononcer sur la première
subvention de l'association des
locataires de trappes et d'île de france
alors qu'elle avait décidé a pris cette
décision en commission finalement les
élus la majorité l'opposition ont voté à
après plusieurs prises de parole et ils
ont voté contre
conclusion ce n'est pas de leur ressort
de soutenir ce type de structure des
points environ quand même a fait
l'unanimité rassurer nous il y avait de
nombreux de nombreux points et bien
évidemment beaucoup ont fait l'unanimité
les élus ont par exemple décidé de
soutenir les librairies indépendantes en
les exonérant totalement de cotisation
foncière des entreprises pareil pour les
cinémas qui réalisent moins de 450 mille
entrées par an la droite et gauche ont
également soutenu l'association club et
climat énergie de 50 ans à hauteur de
15000 euros ou encore différentes
associations culturelles du
territoire voilà pour quelques-uns des
nombreux points qui ont été abordés hier
pour cette conférence
réunion de rentrée pour les élus de
l'agglo et bien merci à wilfrid pour
toutes ces précisions